[Music]
we are going to talk about johnny depp
and amber heard
what i need you to do
us or the listeners the listeners okay
is
calm the fuck down
um and allow us to with levity
and uh incisive commentary be able to
make fun of everyone involved um it is
my belief i won't speak for anyone else
on this podcast that um
because they both suffer from extreme
codependence addiction uh uh most
importantly for at least this podcast
and my point of view and my ability to
comment on this in a way that i think no
one is commenting on um uh severe love
addiction which is something that i
identify with uh i'm finding other lies
amazon.com by whitney cummings uh wrote
an entire book on it and um
it is that is one thing no one really
talks about is the impact of love
addiction uh adrenaline addiction etc
and i think that's what this
relationship has been fraught with and
we hope that after listening to this
episode you guys are able to come away
with a little more clarity about
toxic relationships how it clouds our
brain our decision making
uh why when you're in a relationship
that is abusive i'm not saying i'm not
we're not taking sides we i believe
they're both pretty guilty of many
things i think that both of the things
that they uh did uh
wrong are
were probably fueled by not only
uh substance abuse but also the internal
drug cabinet abuse adrenaline dopamine
internal drug coverage
yeah internal drug cap so adrenaline
always turns into dopamine which clouds
are thinking uh we remember things
differently so so we're not taking sides
we're coming after everyone and we're
mad at everyone does that feel fair yeah
yes yes and it's most importantly we're
not making light of domestic abuse in
any way shape or form we just we're
exploring this as a bizarre spec the
bizarre spectacle that it is and we want
to have this a really nuanced uh
conversation about what this trial has
made us learn about ourselves yes our
internalized uh sexism misogyny um our
preconceived notions our projections
of the metoo movement how we look at the
world now post me too sure and all that
uh money that me too raised right um
that has oh i don't mean that seriously
disappeared uh yeah i just i just the me
disappeared because amber pledged it
you don't have any outstanding venmo
requests whitney cummings
i sent you one last night no when you
buy a house you don't
pay all of it in full that is why we had
a mortgage crisis and uh what are the
details details i know and all the
jurors that are like i can't pay my rent
this month what are you talking about
buy a house
we now take a break in this titillating
verbal intercourse to talk about credit
karma when i say credit card i know what
you think going up to one of your
co-workers and putting your hand between
their butt cheeks and do i'm swiping a
credit card
declined we're not talking about that
that is now called a no-no we're talking
about credit karma partners with a wide
range of card issuers so you can be sure
that you are exploring all sorts of
options the way you should also be doing
in your dating life or married life have
you ever been rejected for a credit card
i usually say rejection's god protection
god's protection but in this case
i hate it it happens way too often and
it hurts my feelings that's why credit
karma created karma confidence
technology helping our members apply
with more confidence say that ten times
fast
credit karma confidence you know i will
become
a christian
um that's how emily comes at least we
know that karma confidence is coming
karma uses your credit data or data we
decided data
data
okay emily has been on some datas
recently uh to show you your chances of
approval before you even apply helping
you apply with more confidence comparing
cards on credit karma is a hundred
percent free and won't affect your
credit score that's big that's massive
yeah also what emily says during sex
ready to find the card for you head to
credit karma and check out your
personalized mix of offers ta-dah go to
creditkarma.com or the credit karma app
to find the card for you that's
creditkarma.com do you have any shows to
promote tell us all about it okay so i'm
going to promote some comedy shows okay
because i am what we call
include
and
i have done so many cities include yeah
oh my god are so
it
not
cultured
in french embarrassment that is not
clown in french
okay
we
[Laughter]
yay
okay so what is clown in french i think
it's
pussy
for sure
emily here's the deal about emily she
will die on a hill like this safely and
so will i i just need mouth
she's met her match in terms of who will
die the hardest on such a stupid hill
anyway
i was right you were wrong where are you
going okay you were
even when she's wrong she's right but i
will be eventually right and you will
see because that is my brand
here's the deal i've done what 75 shows
at least i died shot my special it's all
working but also i'm kind of in an
existential crisis so i'm just gonna go
for it and start telling other people's
secrets on stage why not june 24th i'll
be in calgary alberta at prince island's
park i'm doing this with david spade and
donald rawlings i think it's like an
outdoor festival okay so i'm gonna get
lyme disease cool what do i do in
calgary mountain mountain
a
feel like fracking i think they frack a
lot there
you could pan for gold you could get you
could get into the oil business okay
okay yeah well i am in their own
business look at my face
on june 26th i'll be in toronto ontario
where i just was for about a month i
didn't get to enjoy anything there i'm
going to be at danforth music hall maybe
drake will be there
drake stop it with drake every where you
go you especially every
everywhere you go in toronto we're like
walking around getting like this they're
like dude i think drake's he's like the
angeline of toronto that's ex wait
that is like he's like everyone's
freaking out um uh now that i burned
that bridge in july uh i will be at the
west hampton beach new york west hampton
beach performing arts center uh
reschedule dates on september 8th i'm
going to be in cincinnati ohio at the
taft theater september 9th this is going
to be
five days after my birthday
whoa i know so if i'm not in rehab i
will be in philadelphia pennsylvania at
the miller theater you guys know that i
went to college in philadelphia so i
have a lot of amends to make september
10th i'll be in richmond virginia
emily's alma mater
at the national september 24th
charlottesville virginia we'll be at the
paramount we go to uva party
what we try to do on this podcast is go
we don't know
but here are is what we learned about
ourselves and here's the observations we
do have whereas i think we're in a
culture where everyone wants to be like
he's guilty she's guilty right because
we want these like facile simple answers
statements blanket statements we want to
take sides and we like to get
regular
so okay so why don't you to start i'm
just very shy oh right that's true
that's the first thing i say when people
like what are what's whitney like i'm
like fucking shy quiet as mouse that one
do you guys okay so let me okay so i
basically my i have
literally
15 pages of thoughts
on this
i scrolled through the document and my
favorite part was the very last line
which was asterisk woman who farted
question mark
i would just like to say i haven't seen
whitney this passionate about something
since the woolsey fires
the giraffes needed help i literally
haven't well there are two other drafts
uh in sylmar at bob dunn's house but
that's what i'm talking about like burn
it all down whitney knows every single
you can say like we're like hey did you
see that guy do you mean romero like you
know everywhere yeah to be clear here's
why so as someone that i've i've spent
most of and this sounds a little bit
narcissistic and i'm just gonna keep my
insecurity about talking about myself
out of it um but uh because i'm gonna
try to just be of service so so the the
the lot in my life i guess or whatever
thing
that i found myself um a situation
in which
uh
para alcoholism is something where if
you grew up around alcoholism alcoholism
being defined as uh uh being
not having a choice in your anymore in
the way that you are abusing a substance
sex it can be a invisible substance it
can be a person it can be food but you
always say that it's so helpful alcohol
doesn't have to be present in order for
alcoholism to be present alcohol does
not have to be present compulsive
cooking compulsive organizing
compulsive crafting compulsive checking
instagram there it's everywhere we all
have something that gives us the
dopamine we need that we essentially
keep do i mean it's diminishing
dimensional diminishing marginal returns
um which is you continue to do something
despite negative consequences okay what
and this is a relationship where they
stayed together despite negative
consequences and from what i ascertain
it did not seem like either of them
were able to leave because they were
addicted to each other and so love
addiction is something that is like hard
to
be the
champion of because we're all so in love
with being in love yeah and it's so hard
to say that someone's passion we've been
so conditioned to believe that like if
you're fighting you love each other
we're soul mates and we've glamorized
and glorified sid and nancy and all
these relations right relationship movie
stars yeah um
yeah and and so i think that it's to me
i'm like oh my god finally everyone is
seeing
what i have been going through my whole
play out yeah in a destructive way and
they see how
like i've always been the bummer that's
like
if you're if you're super magnetically
attracted to someone you want to marry
them after a month you've got to wait it
takes two years to know someone and you
can only do one two texts a day and one
hang a week in a public place and you
can't go to his house like i have all
these rules that make it so that love
addiction doesn't get triggered in my
brain and i work i've had to work so
hard to stay out of addictive
relationships because i think a lot of
people don't don't realize or maybe they
do but it just hasn't been
sort of publicly shown in a way that
makes it super obvious which is that
uh addictions to people
can be just as destructive in your life
as addictions to alcohol
and drugs absolutely and substances so
you go into a uh an a.a room or an
alcoholics anonymous room and you hear
people say like ah i smoked crack and
then i crashed my car right i drank nine
glasses of wine and then i sold my baby
to a drug dealer whatever right right
right and then al-anons who have done no
substances right necessarily because
normally where the control addicts go
i did all that shit sober yeah yeah yeah
because i was trying to make my guy
jealous right right but what's
interesting about this love addiction is
that there are no love addiction
meetings you know what i'm saying i
think that we just salia is always okay
but but people get it's like it's not as
mainstream what does it stand for
slaa sex and love addicts anonymous it
also includes
sexual anorexia yeah it also includes
parasocial relationships and a lot of
other things so there's so many
resources out there that we just don't
know about it's free therapy it's free
school and most of us grew up watching
disney movies and see and
essentially learning that like love is
all you need all our favorite songs love
is pain all i need is you i die without
you right these really exaggerated sick
i mean imagine if there was a song that
was like
cigarettes i need you to live yeah you
know i love that one love is it's a
great book that sounds like some shit
you would buy a festival ticket to
but i think it's it's really wild
because i spent most of my life in very
addictive destructive relationships with
people not substances not drugs and i
think that's why you're so passionate
about this for lack of a better word and
so knowledgeable about it because it's
so close to you like in a way where i'm
just watching it is like rich people
fighting you know i but it's so
interesting to see it from your
perspective because it's so much more
nuanced i'm just going to say this i
might sound narcissistic i i in the last
month i kind of spent some time like
going like what is my fucking purpose in
this world and if it's to pass on any
wisdom that i got or insight or
like let's learn something from let's
just learn fucking learn something which
is that i talked about in my last
special there's a difference between
empowerment and entitlement and
my i am going to give some advice uh if
you have are abused
for real not saying this isn't real but
if you are
it does not matter whether life is fair
or not you have to fucking
document it yeah that's just when it
happens and by the way i don't care if
you're upset i don't care if you're
confused i shouldn't have to report his
police you have to right so you just
shouldn't have to but you have to yes
sure yeah because there's too many
people right have taken advantage and
it's not your fault
i'm also coming to this as someone that
has been falsely accused of wild shit
right and if we all just gave pete
everyone the benefit of the doubt
we'd
be it has to be innocent until proven
guilty and i i'm probably not the person
that would have thought that 10 years
ago right but now it's just an
unfortunate yeah i'm the bitch i had to
go down to the small claims court and
fight someone who was trying to say that
i hit his cab
he saw me on a billboard i remember this
remember yeah and then they were like oh
this is like a racket they're just like
super you were accused of stealing
the like the rights of the life of
whitney cummings i was the number of
times i was sued for stealing the show
the premise of the show whitney
from other people
was wild
you know but i had everything fucking
documented i had every single email
email oh my god everything and i always
say to you guys put things in email put
things in email just say hey just
confirming i got this like that's why i
don't call
you me
and so so
that that's just it's important to
accept it doesn't have to be fair but a
lot of people do take advantage a lot of
people are not well yeah and here's what
i'll say if i didn't you know
for some weird darwinian survival
instinct start doing comedy and do it
the hard way right if i was even a
little more derailed
and was
um the age i am now in desperate i'd
probably do some crazy shit like that
you know i also on two broke girls it
was about
broke people making money at all costs
i know what desperate people do
thankfully in my desperation i've only
hurt myself right but i can i know what
it's like to be desperate and had i been
a little more desperate i see myself as
a kind of person who's like fuck it i'll
just do that rich guy yeah he doesn't
deserve that money i i know that my
brain could have gone there anyone's
capable of anything anyone's capable of
anything if you have been fucked under
the right circumstances or even not if
you've been no because you go i had this
childhood i've been abused i deserve
this person has more money than they
deserve why not right right yes that's
what your survival brain will do and
take over in order to justify because
your brain is just going i need to
survive right so when people do huckster
shit like that yeah i have compassion
for them right but not me but not me
you're not going to do this to me right
what's fair is fair and so i had a um i
literally just got a tv show and i'm
like just trying to like make a show
about a gender reversal and like hiring
women and like trying to do the right
thing and hiring all my friends and then
i get a call you're being sued by this
cab driver who said you hit his cab
uh in an instant small claims court and
i was like wait what yeah and i look at
it the date i'm like when was that and
then i have all this proof that i was
not even right it was in like venice on
a tuesday at noon i'm like whitney would
never go to the west side let's be
honest
how dare you for an eight dollar
smoothie
i'm good creation i live on the west
side i can't get waiting to come out
unless i'm dying to covet it is the
upper
east side of california anyway that's
how we knew this cab driver was full of
shit
so i was like no i know exactly where i
was i have emails like i can provide all
this proof and then my business manager
was like it's small claims court it's
six to eight thousand dollars this is a
rigmarole that people do
when they know that you're you know a
public figure and busy they don't think
eight thousand six to eight thousand
dollars
they sue you you don't show up to small
claims court and if you don't show up
they automatically get the six thousand
dollars and they go out of their way to
schedule it on a day that they know you
won't come that december 24th christmas
eve am i allowed to say christmas or
around it cancel uh so christmas eve and
i was like oh bitch you don't know who
you fucked with absolutely i don't have
a family that's the only night i'm free
i will be there and my pony story is
closed my best friends were like do not
do this we will make it up in other ways
we both have a very strong sense and
obsession with justice justice i could
not let that a therapist has told me
that i'm obsessed with justice too
that means that you'll be a great
community those comedy brains are very
obsessed with one justice and two serial
killers that's just a fact
correct and so not that those two things
have anything to do with each other i
mean justice for the people that are
killed by a serial killer karma but what
i'll say
is how is there not a car company called
karma um and so
i show up december 24th i'm like oh this
motherfucker does not know
yeah who he's dealing with like i have
nothing to do yeah on december 24th no
one loves me
i
so i go
this motherfucker he's like he's him and
his friends are like laughing he belt
buckles galore i've got my
dude double virgo this bitch i sure i've
got my papers coordinated
emails i literally have emails of me
saying hey i'm in the office come by for
a meeting i have all these testimonies i
have people showing up with me his face
was ashen
horrified but also i was like you have
no idea what you're dealing with yeah
there's no place i'd rather be than
fucking small claims court yeah the case
before i love this the case before me
yeah was a man that was accusing another
man of stealing his bulls his prized
bulls semen at two in the morning he
said i woke up at six a.m to jerk off my
bull
and there was no seamlessly that morning
there was no semen in his dick god and
this is what happened i was
i was i was like this it dude i will
give you six thousand dollars
honestly
that was the warm-up to this by the way
thank you absolutely i am wearing a i am
like you know it's my dream to be a
fucking lawyer so i you know so i've
seen the frivolous cases i i
for a lot of people i'm like good for
you like
you know there's a lot of people with
celebrities they like you know some
celebrities like portion out a
section of their budget every year to
manage
google who emily's worked for um so
i'm rolling in it yeah you know so yeah
so there's a lot and honestly there's
times where i'm like godspeed like i
know that i know a couple people that
are very um famous and rich and
they they're like yeah this
i've had this cleaning lady for 20 years
i pay her this much right and i'm like
does she have insurance she should have
this and she just sued me for like
whatever toxic work environment to
settle for 50 grand i'm like she's 50.
not not a bad idea you're not giving her
insurance you probably make that on your
bank 50 grand on your bank account
interest what right i understand why
she's doing that yeah it's a good racket
not that i support it i'm just saying
it's it's under you can understand
something without supporting it i'm
emotionally sober in love addiction so
i'm not allowed to be in these
relationships so it's like yeah yeah
yeah i get to like so that's interesting
i'm like oh my god
like honestly i'm not even joking it's
like i don't know it's like a sex addict
like watching porn
i get to watch the relationship i wish i
could be in but i can't yeah see because
you're healthy well not healthy i'm just
like you're
so my take has been uh not as noble
which is i've just really enjoyed the
spectacle of it like i think it's
absolutely fucking crazy that there are
so many things going on in the world
right now and all i want to do is watch
like two rich people fight about like
which yacht he lost his finger on like
they're not even just rich people
they're professional actor
and we're wired for a puzzle
and because i like to be
uh
combative and because i
uh i just have decided that if you don't
stand for anything if you stand for
nothing you'll fall for anything and i
am going to be an amber herd stan
no one else is another way reason i have
sided with amber is because i have also
shit in a bed okay not on purpose yes
but i have shit in a bed sure but
instead of saying that it was dog poop i
poured coffee all over it and said
what's that smell it's coffee coffee's
brown poop is brown it was the best
escape i was going to say hold on i'm
with you because i know you shouldn't
have bet also no no i didn't it was my
guess it was on a couch it was in a bus
in texas
no i asked somebody who has who has shot
themselves at the home of a lover let me
just let me time out yeah shitters unite
yeah because i would like to take you
both to small claims court because i i i
have a lot i've done pretty much
everything embarrassing i have never
shit myself so i'm trying to understand
how it happens because maybe she just
did that you're talking liquid poop well
no
it depends
yeah
i can't believe i'm better at something
than you guys i can't i shouldn't what
shitting is where i shine i can do it
when i want where i want when i want
how's it feel to be god's favorite
that's a good point um so okay so the
shitting aside i don't even care about
that because here's what i'll say i just
want to try to explain why it's here
let's go through and talk about our
right now what we are lacking in society
i believe is is the ability to delineate
something that grosses you out from
something that's illegal to something
that turns you off from something that's
illegal we're not talking about whether
she's a good person a cool person or
he's a good person or a cool person or a
consistent person like
what here's what we do and the staircase
uh the original i would watch i'm sure
you guys have watched the fictional or
the the netflix's version
if you watch it it makes you realize how
our brain will build a case to accuse
someone of something based on something
else we don't like so end of episode two
it comes out that he is gay and having a
gay affair yeah and my brain went oh he
killed her and then i was like wait what
right right what does that have to do oh
my god
my reptilian brain is to j is to go he
cheated on her had an affair therefore
he's a murderer right those are
different things
that's my favorite thing your first
thought is your programming your second
thought is who you are love it totally
you're not responsible for your first
thought you are responsible for your
first action yeah
just
i we're getting passionate but that's
what you meant correct right hey y'all
me again missed you this podcast i don't
know if you know but it's sponsored by
better help life can be overwhelming you
know at this point therapy is not really
optional but because it was only
available in such an archaic way and in
such an elitist way until now people are
out there not even knowing they can get
therapy online with better help it's a
customized to your needs it's it offers
video phone even live chat sessions with
your therapist so you don't even have to
see anyone on camera if you don't want
to yeah it's much more affordable than
in-person therapy good for you listeners
get 10 off their first month at
betterhelp.com whitney that's
betterhelp.com and if you can't spell
help they can help you and you know
what's really funny when you're with
your better help counselor
is uh starting session off with well
you better help
they love it better therapy is the new
like six two do you know what i'm saying
like if i find out a guy's in therapy
i'm like
that's yeah yeah you know just put it in
your hinge profiles everyone so speaking
of best fiends
once you download best fiends you can
play it anywhere and you know this but i
need to remind you because you're not
listening right you don't listen right
even without an internet connection
which is great if you're stuck without
wi-fi which we almost always are correct
not because we don't pay the bills not
because we don't have a team of people
whose only job is to make sure we get
wi-fi
doesn't matter okay wi-fi is a sham
it's never worked right it never will
work so look i am the kind of person who
needs my brain to be engaged at all
times it's called running from demons it
doesn't matter yeah but the point is
i i can't deal with the fact that
sometimes i'm on a plane and there's no
wi-fi sometimes i'm at the american
specifically terminal there's no wi-fi i
have library insurance don't give a shit
and uh sometimes i'm at my own house and
you know what the other day got on a
plane was working away on the plane ooh
like a big busy little chipmunk i got
all kinds of things coming down the
pipeline
took my computer out cause i'm gonna
take care of myself cause i'm a big girl
and i put the computer in the back
pocket of the thing i know how this ends
yep yeah me too yesterday i had to
seriously say to alex he's he's we're
like trying to watch something the new
carlin document or something i was like
i just i can't get the tv to work and
he's like just use your computer and i
was like oh my computer's at the airport
like that's just something that comes
out of my mouth on a regular it's there
like most of them most of my shit is at
the airport that's true collect tons of
fiends that you get powered up as you
play more levels every win brings new
challenges there are thousands of
puzzles to play i'm on level 200. that
is very impressive seems like you and
the new guy are spending a lot of
quality time together
download best fiends for free from the
app store or google play plus earn even
more with five dollars worth of in-game
rewards when you reach level five that's
friends without the r best fiends you're
welcome this is over
we're doing this mass shaming
town square hanging
roman coliseum
i don't like that you cheated on your
husband therefore you murdered
yeah right your second husband right
that's not how it works like our brain
wants to take shortcuts and i'm very
anti-shortcut because that's not
emotionally sober and that's what we do
to feel bad about ourselves you cheated
on your boyfriend there for your fucking
murderer and you're over yeah and i'm
going to say this again i've been
accused of a lot of things that i didn't
do
and a lot which as a justice person is
the worst possible but as an actor but
to say like she did this she made this
joke therefore she did this she said
this thing on a red carpet therefore she
did this like our brain wants to do that
but it's cheap and it's unintelligent
and i always on this podcast i'm going
to want to go for intelligent let's play
at the top of our intelligence and
so look
i also think it's important to identify
red flags i think there's a huge lesson
watching amber testify
really made me grow totally because
i do
let's say all this happened to her
let's say it all happened
the way that she is describing it is
undermining
her she's undermining herself by the way
that she's saying it so one of the
biggest red flags in aca allanon uh coda
recovery is people that exaggerate so
and the way that they say it and the
words that they choose to use
so if you
are truly abused or something truly bad
happens to you by your boss or your
co-worker or your boyfriend or your
girlfriend or whatever it is
the onus is on you sorry to be clear and
concise
and unemotional and that's also why
sorry but that's also why it's so
important to like record everything
document everything like journal write
it all down whatever it is because also
when you're in a like repetitive
traumatic situation like that your brain
will literally forget things and like
create false memories it will it will
leave things out it will add things in
like you will literally just forget what
actually happened so unless you have
like a real time sort of like
explanation to yourself of what was
going down
just by the nature of being traumatized
your brain will work to protect you
correct from your own trauma
so it will it will change your lived
experience in your head we just had
morin surf on the podcast he's a
neuroscientist we're not just a couple
of whores saying this neuroscientists
said um very clearly that every time we
tell a story we change the story based
on what people respect everything we
share members
i'm not saying she's exaggerating but
the way
that she is saying something is
undermining what she is saying and i
think that for women men in business
when you're talking to your boss when
you're talking to your coworker when
talking to your boyfriend your mom your
dad whatever as soon as you get start
exaggerating or uh using words that are
histrionic for no reason a hyperbolic
exactly and making yourself um uh
for lack of a better word a fucking
valley girl so and it's also worth
noting this because when you are on a
first second third fourth and fifth date
if people talk like this get the fuck
out because you're next this was 10
years ago yeah
that did come up when they were showing
her like photo evidence where the
metadata had been redacted and she was
like
well
look like i can't i can't that's a
picture of wine spilled on the floor i
can't tell you when that is because you
redacted the metadata you've had 10
years totally totally but she was like
how would i know which floor this is and
like what what bottle of wine this was
on what like given night that wine was
thrown in all of the nights that was
okay but you're saying you knew
everything about everything else right
no yeah yeah yeah
yeah you should have sent an email you
documented most that's the other thing
you documented everything when he was
sleeping every night but not that like
you it is the onus on you to
um advocate for yourself and know what
the fuck you're talking about in every
scenario measure twice cut once 101.
right so
there's a difference betw
you know me i'm a language dork there is
a difference between punching and
slapping yeah there is oh yeah there is
yeah they're both illegal
to both genders
but if it's a slap you can't say punch
right and
it's important as you move forward in
life that words matter um what is it is
the four agreements your word is law
say what the fuck you're saying right
yeah and stop with the verbal diarrhea i
see it all the time just you can say
i need a second
may i have a second to think about this
do not say something before you're ready
to say it because if you say he punched
me and then camille his lawyer goes well
he has rings on every finger
if it was a slap and you had said that
you would have been fine if all of this
is true she's undermining herself sure
so my point is learn how to not
undermine yourself in your work in your
relationships in your family situations
because
our families that are narcissistic
family members are fucking with that
have cast us in our role as
the daughter that's uh was a mess and
now it isn't like you have to actively
play defense on the stereotypes against
you on your own past whatever and you
have got to be
impeccable with your word that's what
it's called in the four agreements be
impeccable with your word know what the
fuck you're going to say shut your mouth
until you know what you're going to say
because you're just going to embarrass
and undermine yourself so people are
waiting for her to fuck up right and
she's not taking that into account you
cannot use the fact that like i'm a girl
so i should be able to be vague and
sloppy just because i'm a woman that's
just not how it works anymore you know
i mean it never worked that way and you
also
to never admit wrongdoing is a red flag
so if you're in a relationship with
someone that that is this ostensibly
according to her abusive conniving
disgusting
you have to be able to say like i had a
part in this right and until you can
you're completely fucked well that's why
it's so important to ask people that
you're dating about like their past
relationships yeah because if they go
like oh my god he was a narcissist he
was a piece of shit all he did was lie
to me like all he did was do this like
you stayed for four years likely true
like like if you are if that is your
lived experience and that is true it is
probably very like
traumatic and like i understand that
however if you if you claim innocence
and don't say like
don't own the fact that like you had a
part in that or like i egged him on i
thought it was like attractive when he
would get aggressive like it's if you
don't own the parts of it that you did
play we both drank a lot he was hot he
was older than me
he had money tango and i got confused
but also when people that are not
psychiatrists start diagnosing their ex
oh yeah which is that to me is tricky
the more someone else accuses someone of
being a narcissist
tricky yeah jim saying yeah you can like
narcissism and malignant narcissism are
slightly different but narcissism is
something that i think is like it's like
the new random people just kind of like
throw that word around they don't really
know what it means gaslighting correct
psychopath sociopath like it's a little
bit tricky of a
um thing to just like throw around which
is just another sidebar that's hilarious
to me is that this that no psychiatrist
agree on everything it's so
well if they agree with whoever hired
that i was going to say that gets into
the thing that expert witnesses that is
such an insane like as someone that is
an aspiring expert witness
how dare you i think you would be great
at it
excellent excellent i would just be like
i've witnessed this trial for five
minutes and i already know it but like
the fact that these people are being
paid to get on the sand and like like
one of the legal teams is paying them
it's not like they're doing this pro
bono it's right
do we know i think it's usually a lot
that's wild to me because it's
no amount of money to me is worth
being full of shit or being biased
especially as a psychiatrist i mean it's
weird because the the psychiatrist curry
who was johnny depp psychiatrist i have
to be honest i think that people are
being wildly unfair to her just because
she's pretty and maybe had some work
done not triggered um
but
and then the amber psychiatrist
is
you know has not put a ton of work into
her appearance i'm just gonna fucking
say it and everyone's taking her more
seriously but she is the one that
actually is using bogus science so she's
going she in order to do the um trauma
the ptsd
evaluation according to the rules that
are made i'm not saying the rules are
perfect you have to do it within a year
of the trauma and she did not do it
within a year of the trauma she said oh
well i jogged amber's memory so that it
would be in a year of a trauma like
that's not that's not real so it's weird
because i look i'm just gonna calm
myself out i looked at her and i was
like she probably knows what she's
talking about
curry is pretty
and she probably knows less of what
she's talking about that's literally
what i thought i was like what does this
bitch know like she's pretty she's got
mac lip glass on she like did her hair
she's she has great highlights
what the fuck does she know and then i
saw the other one and i was like oh this
bitch knows what's up right but she is
the one that actually
conducted the test completely improperly
and then tried to backtrack she didn't
even make notes in the fucking shit they
were like you left all these blank and
she's like well i have
written it somewhere else they're like
what like but i found myself wanting to
believe her so much more because she
didn't put an effort into her appearance
yeah that's an interesting introspective
acknowledgement
um i would just like to say that um
everybody's salty because amber scored
in the 98th percentile of the ptsd test
because she's an overachiever and she
worked really hard at it so also i will
say
i it really pisses me off anyone
listening to this is like
anti-woman
it is so fucking fishy to me when
someone banks on well i'm a woman so no
one can challenge me or else they're
sexist or they're abusers and so this
whole i'm invincible because i'm a woman
thing is the worst thing to happen to
women you know the idea is
the idea is to be equal not superior and
you're trying to be superior and i don't
fuck with that shit right you know and
so i think that um i think it's
important to talk about human magnet
syndrome okay uh human magnet syndrome
is basically there's there's two books
that i think if anyone is like
captivated by this and like
like me uh or has any kind of like
um i hate the word triggered um but any
kind of like
wanting to understand what happened here
there's a book called getting the love
you want by harvard hendrix which is a
game changer or if you find yourself
being in in relationships where you're
like
i
this is dramatic this is painful
this is diminishing marginal returns yet
i can't leave and i don't know why
getting the love you want which by
harvard hendricks we're all attracted to
people who have the negative qualities
of our primary caretakers until we do
some kind of healing and then number two
human magnet syndrome which is like if
you're magnetically attracted to someone
and you're kind of not sure why and you
can't leave even if you wanted to and
you're exhausted and all you do is fight
etc
please read that there's a couple things
that um
when you're in a situation where you're
constantly trying to change someone
where you're constantly trying to fix
someone rescue someone doing the three
m's mothering martyring and
micromanaging which is what i heard in
all those recordings that's i have
actually have a choker like you know how
you have one with your dog's names on it
i have one that says that i'm
motherfucking micromanager i have one
that says amber heard okay keep doing
it and uh
uh no yours is never feels heard um
amber never feels heard over here is
misheard i'm like i get why you feel
like no one hears you i know it's your
name
your is traumatic um so there's little
things like little tools like
for you know 28 days you need to
extricate yourself from the situation to
essentially desensitize yourself and
lower your tolerance to the adrenaline
that the chaos is making for you but
also the same way that like a postpartum
depression is very very real but a lot
of people a lot of women that i know are
like
i'm also just so fucking tired it's not
always a matter of diagnosis but a lot
of times it is absolutely chemical but a
lot of women i know are like i think i
was just sleep deprived so when you're
in toxic relationships a lot of times
you're just sleep deprived and you
cannot fucking make proper judgments
you're drinking you're using drugs
you're this you're that you're like so
many things get uh uh pull your shit
together for 28 days stop doing
substances try to find a way to sleep
eight hours and then start making some
decisions i know it sounds like a tall
order for aqua women for someone i'm
looking for someone that normally sleeps
18 hours hey listen i'm coming from the
place of amber camp this whole show
uh you guys don't know i'm joking i'm
gonna put it in the bio you just brought
up hitler for no reason earlier let's
stop talking about camps
so
i think it's also a big thing that i can
be helpful for with you guys is that
when you get into a relationship number
one look for all the red flags if
someone in a relationship is only
blaming their exes and takes no
responsibility for their own shit if
somebody um
uh is only blaming others if someone
exaggerates it was like the worst day of
my life
he
my boss was a nightmare my boss was the
meanest person on earth that's how
two-year-olds talk right instead of my
boss was kind of toxic we didn't get
along we didn't get along whatever it is
my boss was the meanest person ever it
was the worst time of my life right you
know i mean if that was the worst time
of your life your life is going pretty
well yeah so also important to know your
partner's love language i know this
sounds dorky and conflict resolution
strategy when i hear them fighting by
the way as soon as you start recording
your fights get out red flag talk about
speaking of which number one
and
no their conflict resolutions if you and
your partner do not have a compatible
conflict resolution strategy you guys
cannot emily and i have had conflicts
before we have a compatible conflict
resolution strategy holding hands and
crying holding hands crying
it's important to understand um
that uh i look i am as of now i am
fearful avoidant in in
with someone else with someone that's
preoccupied i'm fearful avoidance so
that means if someone is really obsessed
with
solving the problem with me yeah i have
i need to find any choice okay it's
smothering to me it exhausts me okay i
feel um
uh
pressure
i feel pressure
but if someone is fearful avoidant
i get preoccupied and i want the person
to yeah you know what i'm saying so your
attachment strategy and your uh conflict
resolution strategy changes george haas
um
allen on aca can help you with this kind
of stuff your love language is also a
big one so when someone so to me when
she said uh his assistant texted me
right he was gonna be late or whatever
it was sorry to do that impression of
her she doesn't sound like that she
speaks in like kind of in english she
speaks like an angel she speaks like
she's from troy
she's helena maybe yeah exactly i'd
fight an army for her
and so
i don't know i i'd stick myself in a
horse for that girl i love that all
blondes just like support all blondes
it's like there's a weird fucking call
because you guys know you're going down
in a blaze of glory and so the maryland
effect what was i saying
oh uh
love when you heard her say
um
his assistant texted me he was gonna be
five minutes later i go holy shit her
love language is communication and words
of affirmation right that is not mine
right in the slightest if my dude's
assistant texted me i'd be like he's an
assistant
he's gonna be late that's why you're
always sending me nudes and then being
like four of these
and so um so i don't give a shit i don't
need words of affirmation i don't need
you to tell me you love me in fact when
people give me words of affirmation
quote it makes me suspicious why do you
have to say it right oh no right that's
right i'm a big words of affirmation i
am not because anyone can i grew up and
i are big words
i grew up with anyone can say anything
and i'll believe it you're actually
that's true but i still believe it but
your actions are the only thing i
believe so i go
don't tell why are you telling me love
me right i would know if it was true
right
and alex and i we got
many fights about this because he'd be
like i love you i'm like yeah i'll let
you know when you love me mm-hmm i don't
need to hear the breaks there buddy
this guy i know he like i feel
manipulated don't tell me that right
i'll know i'll that was our whole thing
i'll tell you when you love me when i
feel it i'll know virgo insane double
burger how dare you um and then
for me
uh my love language is gifts
yes that's very true i i can't
necessarily tell you how i feel about
you right i can't necessarily
communicate it but i can say i bought
this lisa frank
bedazzle but he's this weird bedazzled
corset t-shirt yeah right you've been
you've been on the receiving end
yeah yeah
with a bra built in which i think was
like the main message of that
please wear a broader like we're really
tired about it
your tits are very saggy grace
um and i go oh my god
i know this would make this person happy
and i want to give this person a gift i
did it before i had any kind of
resources i loved doing it because i my
thing is words fail i grew up hearing a
bunch of words that were in congress
with people's actions and i go words
mean nothing i want to see your eye so i
always go like i know this is going to
make you happy right right right you
know so that's that's mine it's it's not
yours aren't worse than mine your love
language it doesn't matter but if you
guys are not able to receive love
language i also don't like receiving
gifts which is weird sure um i only and
that's tricky
as we accept the dipty candle keep those
coming up you're as you're
uh you know taking a break from my
bombastic uh
die at the hill of emperor's bit right
now um it is tricky when your love
languages are different because
i try to match your love language and
i'm like well witness love language is
gift giving so i should give her a gift
then i go emily you're taking away my
ability right to debt myself right right
i want to buy my own dipty candles so
that i feel the adrenaline of spending
too much on a candle right
absolutely and just like amber we've
both been cross persecuted
so so it's important to know in your
friendships your uh work relationships
and you have to do this work i'm sorry
you do the we have too many tools we
have too much research as a society for
you to be like oh i did the best i could
i just love too much if you didn't love
in a way that they understand right it
doesn't fucking matter and you get no
points for that and you're not a martyr
and you're not a victim or you're
martyring yourself and you're not a
victim so it's like i get to learn okay
emily's love language is word of
affirmation grace's love affirmation our
love language is physical tickets to
coachella that's it um
take artists
to
a pool where you buy clothes in silver
like
calvin harris
he's dead i can introduce you to anne
hathaway on corydon one night is my love
language that's the only one but you
have to under if you really are having
this much discord there is a love
language dissonance right
that's not to say that there are any two
love languages that are incompatible but
if you aren't understanding where the
other person is coming from and what the
other person is looking for that's when
you are running into problems yeah
you're going the same way that people on
twitter and people in the zeitgeist now
want everyone to talk the way that they
talk vote the way they vote i want you
to love the way i love i want you to
live the way i live i want you to make
the choices the way i make choices
without any concept of like
let me understand why you think that way
because i love you so much i want to
learn right yeah you know what i'm
saying so if it's not just like kismet
you guys both are on the same page
constantly like it's pointless like like
my dude needs words of affirmation i
hate doing it
but i have to figure it out so does your
show runner i'll be like
i'm sorry
i'm not but i have to say that sometimes
for sure we both know i was right but
you need me to say i'm sorry so i i need
to go regroup right and read stella
adler's acting book so that i can come
back and and try to watch this master
class because
for the longest time i was like i'm not
sorry do you want me to say i'm sorry
and then later
i'm gonna lose respect for you because
you accept an apology that i was
obviously just saying because that's
your fucking love language you nerd yeah
that sounds reasonable to me yeah so but
you have to eat a dick sometimes i mean
i won't if his love language is sucking
dicks
favorite bible verse i would do anything
okay so those are the very okay wait but
what else do you have anything else
before i interrupt you here are the red
flags about amber heard and these i am
making oh i'm gonna put my ear buffs on
i am making i feel like you do have a
pair of earmuffs you fucking ski lodge
whore
so number one
[Laughter]
so
like snow bunny
she did
make fun of him crying
there was a clip of her going like i
walked in and like he was sobbing crying
like a grown man was like crying and
before i know it he
starts crying
and you know like i i
have never seen
an adult man cry
um i didn't really see my dad cry at my
grandma's funeral you know just it's
weird
and he's crying
tears i mean just falling out of his
eyes he gets down on his knees and he
grabs my hands and he's touching my
hands and he's
saying to me i will never do that again
i'm so sorry baby i i put the fucker
away i thought i killed it and it's it's
done i i i i thought i put the monster
away
and i've done it before it's done
but on his knees
that's tricky to me mm-hmm jim saying so
if you're a woman that is accusing man
of being like a toxic abusive male and
like him crying is like a turn off to
you right so for a lot of people that
have personality disorders etc don't
like when other people cry
it makes them feel pressure and they're
they don't get to be the victim in the
scenario taking a quick break to talk
about my corns so
i
have a perfect five on wiki feet i
believe it's five out of five very
impressive if it's out of ten i'm gonna
need to go take a walk if i'm just
finding that out no don't put any more
stress on your feet it is almost
it is almost impossible for me to find
comfortable shoes that's why i always
wear sneakers i have very wide feet i
just do i'm a 10 wide i can only wear
certain sneakers i can't wear a lot of
the the men
manolo
jimmy yes christian
they make these little tiny things i
have giant feet these rothy's shoes
which i think they got famous at first
because angelina jolie wore a pair on a
plane if someone with a billion dollars
is like these are the shoes i'm wearing
you know something's good they are so
look how okay so see how they look thin
and then you put your foot stretchy i
know but my foot do you see how wide my
foot goes yeah and you walk and it's
just so comfortable yeah there you go
they bend oh yeah yeah that's the best
pack great for packing i was just in new
york for three weeks i had not near for
two days
i put them folded them up jammed them on
either side of my backpack and guess
what not that i've ever spilled anything
because i'm not a clutchy person and i'm
not a mindless idiot
and i don't have six or seven beverages
around me at all times that are open but
completely full so
you can pop them in the washing machine
there's one in my house somewhere they
are the perfect shoes for commuting and
traveling and everyone notices have you
seen the i got when i wear the leopard
print one i get stopped
on the street people lose their minds
yeah there's a there's like all these
different print ones one is is it
leopard or cheetah i don't know yes well
yeah and you get stopped on the street
you get stopped at you know like on
planes you get stopped in airports you
get stopped everywhere because you can
wear these literally everywhere discover
the versatile styles that you can wear
like i said absolutely anywhere and get
twenty dollars off your first purchase
at rothys.com
classic that's r-o-t-h-y-s dot com slash
whitney for twenty dollars off your
first order classic i feel like emily is
thriving in her life
because with thrive market you can shop
everything from healthy pantry
essentials and sustainable meat and
seafood to non-toxic cleaning products
and beauty products all delivered right
to your door so usually
i am trying very hard to eat healthy
um
i really do people always ask about my
energy level it really is about what you
put in your body and how you're going to
fuel yourself yesterday i had to do this
shoot whatever i always have with me
these mary's gone crackers always i am
obsessed i can't see those without
thinking about me either i just am at a
point where i have no excuses with
eating garbage anymore and i also buy
from thrive market to get a bunch of
stuff throw it in my bag when i travel
so i'm not eating trash in hotel rooms
almond flour cauliflower powder i mean i
dare you to find gluten in any of these
boxes they're making crackers out of
things i didn't even know you could make
crackers out of
you know what i mean adrenal chrome
yeah
that's my favorite thing here's the
thing usually when you try to
be healthy with what you put in your
body on your body you get punished by
having to go to seven different websites
you go to trader joe's you have to go to
whole foods you have to get the co-op
you have to go to the yeah like the
things when you join thrive market
you're joining a community
you are joining a community of one
million other members and sponsoring a
family in need at the same time yeah
they have a little charitable aspect to
it so not only do not have to run all
over town looking for your little
seeds and nuts right but you can also
help people while you do it at one
convenient place you guys if anything
you don't have to go to the farmer's
market oh my god farmer's market not
romantic
dot com slash dive to get eighty dollars
in free groceries that's thrive market
dot com slash dive thrive market dot com
slash dive that can't be right that
can't that could be right
but i've said it thrice why can't it be
right and thus it is so thrive mark dive
why would it be die endive
thrive because thrive rhymes with the
dive let me just i mean i pull it right
from the copy but god
doesn't make a lot of sense thrive
market slash what if i go what if i try
what if
there's no way i could have fucked that
up that many times
it goes to the website it does yeah okay
then we're good okay now back to us or
is anyone here in debate club sometimes
you're assigned the role you don't want
to fight for and you have to do it and
that is what i'm doing for everyone
today
number four
um
tammy craig baker johnny depp made a
movie called
rango
about a beloved animated
chameleon
talk about looking at things granularly
chameleons are masters of deception so
such a great point number two for both
people both of these people win prizes
for how good they are lying we get it
johnny chameleon culture
is your costume
what's that wait hold on hold on he
appropriated chameleons
i don't have a lot to work with his
communion is sinbad at the apollo
both of them
both of them dress like they're
on the road to perdition
it's weird
first of all to whitney make first of
all to your point imagine watching this
trial as a sommelier
you made that very small smart point yes
i'm just obsessed with who would be more
uh obsessed with slash shocked at this
trial then this kid is a sammier because
all imagine why this wine it was thrown
against the wall imagine being a son
which by the way she's
learning to be a samia or she's getting
she's like in some way class yeah well
it's getting spilled all around her all
the time she may as well she might as
well learn what the fuck it is
as we say in writer's room i bump i bump
on
i bump i bump on
he spent
12 000 on bottles of wine he had them
flown in on private jets
and then he threw them
across the room you just have to make
sure your shit is bulletproof
as someone that has dated a lot of
addicts stopping jealous i have a dog
shirt that matches my mug
people love me
uh
you don't waste your substance
so that's where i bump the only blind
spot is that you are so
you have worked so hard on yourself yeah
you have
done so much work
that
it seems
crazy to you that someone else wouldn't
take advantage of those tools and do
that like
you can get a book at a library and
start this work like you can talk to a
better health counselor promo code
whitney and do this work
but i think
some people are still so in the dark
like you do say something all the time
that makes a lot of sense like
after doing al-anon
everyone seems crazy what is the thing
that you what is that i'm not saying it
uh
i'm not sure it's like um
the like you're so angry at other like
you get angry at other people because
you're like when they saw this light
why aren't you i didn't see it i was i
was i was put in a situation where i had
to and i i don't want to some people but
that's why but that's the thing is that
like i see what you're saying like it it
reminds me of a situation when i was in
college like which was sort of
like i went to college kind of during
the meeting movement i like started
college before that happened
whatever okay i'm literally the youngest
person
and who dresses like the oldest person
it sounds is that
from b arthur's estate
yes exactly but um but but it was sort
of like
it was kind of just at the beginning of
like mandatory like sexual assault
training and like that kind of thing
happening on college campuses which is
obviously a good thing but like i
remember being in this situation where
like i had been really drunk and hooked
up with somebody and like didn't feel
great about it but was talking with my
roommate about it and like these two
older girls who lived in our dorm and
like i was sort of like making a joke
out of it and one of them just looked at
me and was like you don't have to laugh
about this if you don't want right sure
yeah and it's that thing and in that
moment i was like oh i don't know what
that was like it wasn't it wasn't
assault i would never call it that like
it but it was a great area that made me
really uncomfortable and i felt violated
sure and so it was like oh i never
realized that like i
that's like it was it was like naming it
to taming it like it was that was the
first time that i felt empowered to like
claim that experience as something that
i had had and then like then that helped
me to move forward and like understand
it but sometimes it takes somebody else
or something else happening to like make
you realize that something that had
happened in the past that your first
inclination was to laugh about is not
necessarily disturbing
and i also think it's it's my um
uh role as auntie whitney big sister to
go okay
you said it felt violating and then you
go feelings aren't facts yeah are they
facts right it might be a fact right and
you might be minimizing because of a big
trauma response it's either to minimize
or exaggerate right yeah so i'm i'm
looking at someone i think in this trial
that's exaggerating my instinct is to
minimize right right so that's also a
trauma response that's not healthy or
good but when it goes someone violated
me now it is my choice to see if i'm
gonna re-violate myself with this
absolutely and make sure this is
permanent for the rest of my life so it
is new yeah it is new that it when i was
22 and had that same thing happen to me
um three years ago um
am i gonna tweet about it right or am i
going to don't just do something sit
there am i going to go you know what but
if you're still sick then you tweet
about it totally which is why i'm having
this this podcast to go if something
horrible happened to you in college or
like that whatever
document everything
send emails and then decide do i want
this person to haunt me
until i'm 36 you're gonna be violated at
some point in your life it's not about
if it's about when man woman whatever
the fuck you're gonna feel it whether
it's a feeling or a fact it doesn't
really matter and then you have to
decide am i gonna further
violate myself by making this my
permanent internet imprint
or my permanent story i decided in my
head right and you're at a crossroads
where you can go you know what
we both were i look at a couple and i'm
trying not to minimize ever again
because if someone's a predator that i
witness being a predator and can hurt
other people i think i've made very
clear that i do something about it yeah
yes but if i go you know what
as much as i want
as
good as it feels to be a victim
oh no i was your face he was should he
have done he's made different decisions
yes should i have made different
decisions totally the best thing for my
mental state
is to not rewrite the story to go like
you know what
i don't think this is someone that is a
psychopath or a sociopath or someone
that is going to harm somebody else i'm
going to harm somebody else
like
i i sh
i should have coulda woulda yeah
i should have been more clear i didn't
have the tools yeah exactly and then
once you learn those things the next
time you're in a situation that feels
similar you go i'm actually gonna go
here's the thing
you cannot spend your life
hoping the other person will just do the
right thing it doesn't work that way it
doesn't and so it's a hard lesson to
learn when you go i just hope this
person does the right thing that's why i
do equine therapy i mean you've seen it
the other like
it i i wish silence wasn't
a yes i wish right i'm just gonna go
along with this and hope this person
just realizes it will never happen with
your best friend with your boss with
your girlfriend with your boyfriend
they'll just come to their senses
eventually that is like allenic thinking
that has taken me so long if i just sit
here and take it this person will
realize how mean they're being if i just
sit here and take it this person will
realize i'm being violated we'll realize
that i'm uncomfortable yeah right
those days are over yeah you know and i
wish i i
maybe the tides are changing and i i
don't know
you know because now there's like
consent apps and stuff like that
but
you know i i can't overstate how much
evidence i have that if you just sit
there and do the right thing
uh that other person will not
do the right thing right right based on
yeah you're waiting right i think the
issue then which is like and not not at
all saying this in like a victim blamey
way like like the the issue then is like
if you have the tools and the
wherewithal to be able to do that most
of us don't right most of us don't i
didn't fight flight and freeze right
right i was not fight until
much later in life i was freeze my
entire teenagers my college years but
like i think that
these difficult tricky conversations are
about like
know where you come from know what
you're up against know what your
internalized need to be liked compliant
we are wired to not want to be the
squeaky wheel we are wired men are wired
to not want to be the bitch
who says i'm abused by a woman and women
are wired to not want to be
abused by the man or difficult or shrill
or annoying or
um
and when you say that it's interesting
to me because it's disappointing because
i feel like i
i came up at a time
um where if if you made out with a guy
and didn't yeah fuck him right you gave
me blue balls
right you were physically hurting this
man right and you just were like well
okay i still have like a fucked up thing
about that i mean that's how you get a
boner then that's my response that's my
responsibility which is yeah so i have
to handle it fucked up and they're like
oh
my niece felt that way i'd murder
someone like it's crazy yeah the guys
would kill over and be like oh yeah they
can't just go jerk off right that's your
fucking problem totally whatever yeah
i'm like gorgeous
fucking i'll just give you a picture of
yourself i'll give you my headshot but
like but i think it's really important
to know like the guilt of life oh yeah
oh i turned you on i took it this far
but then but
what we do in the equine therapy is like
you can say no at any moment yeah you
can leave at any moment you want yeah
but this paralysis that comes over us
and i think that that's the biggest
conversation with all this is like like
we have to decide
how much agency we have i want to be
able to run the world and have my finger
on the nuke button but i can't leave if
i'm uncomfortable all joking aside like
if you're feeling this way like get a
book right you know what i mean like
especially somebody in this situation
like
nobody
i can't imagine that there would like
you were like you were saying that there
would be any or many people in their
lives who would have the incentive to
say
you need to get out truly the only like
not the only reason i do this podcast
but like the reason you always see me
coming back to this is because it's like
when i see women men whatever not
achieving the goals they achieved i'm
like did you lose six years on an
addictive relationship where you wasted
a bunch of time
fighting with some fucking girl or some
fucking guy instead of like doing the
work a boring relationship is how a
great career is made right you know you
look at it you know yeah that's like
that's like anxious attachment 101 the
secure attachment feels fucking boring
correct
it is such a it's such a massive like
somebody with an extremely anxious
attachment style like it is such a
hurdle to get over because you go on a
date with somebody and like
it might be a perfectly fine date you
might have a nice time whatever but like
the spark's not there you're like that's
the excitement like i know that they're
gonna text me tomorrow that's so fucking
boring like like they're needy like
secure attachment becomes needy boring
this is what this is where i become the
annoying
like older generation person who goes
why the fuck our 22 year olds
mad at people for saying merry christmas
or
they them instead of spark passion
versus toxic those are the words that
actually need to change because that's
what's actually holding people back so
you've lost six years of your life
because you thought that this toxic yeah
depleting addictive relationship was
passion and butterflies twin flames
instead of an obstacle
depleting exactly right i just think
it's a super tall order
for
to expect that
self-awareness of two very deeply
wounded for sure people totally which is
by the way as a deeply wounded person
right this is how this is how it ends
this is it ends you're 36 years old and
you're still talking about something
that happened when you were 26 so
so how would you if how would you if you
were amber if there's an amber
listen in him
met a 22 year old let's be and when
clear but part of it let's be clear he
met a 22 year old who was beguiling in
all kinds of ways and fit right into his
trauma and when i'm gonna marry you
right you know what i'm saying so
they're both culpable right so if you're
a johnny or an amber
i also think another thing about
power and money and wealth is that you
don't ever think you're the problem do
you know what i'm saying and what i'm
wondering is what would your advice be
to listeners who may
be a johnny or an amber on a smaller
scale or johnny and amber on a bigger
scale whatever
what would be the
red or the indicator that even if they
don't think they need al anon or a book
or you know
what sort of thing about it just to
start thinking about it this is what
like i think that the main al-anon shit
is uh aca elena i remember the first
time i went to elena i was drug there
tooth and nail
and was like i'm not fucking going to
this program because other people are
flawed right and so i was like and
someone had to try i mean that's why
service is like the main component
because you go hey
well you know what
will you just come with me to this thing
right yeah
you might not need like i had someone
right who was an addict a a
a relationship i was in that was a very
intense love addiction relationship that
i was trying to rescue mother martyr
michael managed this person trying to
get them sober back and forth like
literally like taking apples out of his
house so he wouldn't make crack pikes
out of them
learning spanish to be able to talk to
drug dealers and he
just his service and his program of n a
and a a was if someone is hurting you be
of service and try to get them to a
meeting if they get it great if they
don't find it right but i i tried yeah
because you don't know until you don't
know and you know once a humpty dumpstee
it's like falls off the wall there you
can't put them back together again so if
she has an epiphany great if she doesn't
find it right but if you don't have
someone to grow to take you
totally which is like you know look at
the pattern of your life you're then
you're listening to this podcast i don't
know this podcast in my book like all of
that was of service
i don't love talking about this i didn't
want to write a book about addiction
it's just like that's what you do
if you used to be in the fog and you go
i'm going to be of service because i
know how insidious this disease is i
know it's a disease that tells you you
don't have a disease it's a disease that
tells you that you're right and everyone
else is wrong what are the chances that
you're right about everything the chance
is
very zero very zero and our ego and our
in what i would say to everyone that
thinks they're right about everything
all the time is that that comes from
like a wounded child who was
confused amber and i feel attacked right
now correct and so why does her sister
have eye bags and she doesn't um so what
i'll say is a lot of times
victims are perpetrators and it's not
your fault it's the same thing of like
okay hey pedophiles were molested
that's that's crazy to hear but like if
you
come out of relationships and go and the
biggest problem was i just loved him too
much or the biggest problem yeah and
then that then listeners that might be a
red flag if you can't identify one thing
you've done wrong
you might have the defense mechanism to
protect yourself and your ego because
you were too criticized as a kid it's
worth exploring and you need to just go
like wait a second like these are tools
that helped me a lot when i was a kid
right when i my narcissistic or or
unintegrated parents that didn't have
tools were criticizing me because they
were insecure i have now internalized
this thing of criticize everyone else
except yourself so that you don't feel
like a complete piece of shit you know
it feels good to blame everyone else but
the only thing that feels better than
that is saying i have a part of this
because if you have a part you can
actually change it right it's the best
feeling in the world to go you know what
emily
what happened the other day hurt me so
bad right
but i can't change you right i can
change me so to go i should have done
this i shouldn't have said that i
shouldn't have said it like that i
shouldn't have um
said it at that time you were going into
a
date whatever
now i can change all of it right that's
the best feeling in the world to go i am
powerless and i can't change you because
i'm not god right i'm not that arrogant
if it's all my fault now i can fix it
right right so there's a weird um
and then when i watch her i go this is
someone that nothing is her fault
and that to me is hell
when nothing is your fault yeah that's
hell because you can't change anything
and i'm in her head going oh my god
honey if you just went
i was a kid i was young i drank two i
did molly too
i knew that you were sick and suffering
with an addiction and i tried to control
you i tried to change you i stayed when
i should have left i had all these
people around me that were enabli like
then you can move on with your life and
you can get closure but if everything is
always the other person's fault you're
always stuck powerless yeah you're
always powerless and the best i mean
i've just and i wouldn't say it if i
hadn't been through it i mean i remember
being in a the couple of abusive
relationships i've been in i ended up
owing them apologies
yeah so what uh my sponsor and therapist
said to me is when i went into program i
was like i don't fucking need to be here
i'm too smart for this i'm only i
literally only went in
so that i could tell all the addicts and
quote abusers in my life
like well i'm going to allen on it was
like it was just right it was just to be
even more superior and then i heard
people go like oh no i had a part in
this i was immature i was childish i
needed to be a victim i was trying to
fix people i was trying to change people
you know how arrogant it is to say like
you're an addict with a disease it's
like yelling at someone to be like why
the fuck do you have cancer
so when i hear her yelling at him about
getting sober
that brings up so much in me because i
know that the reason people um
not the reason a reason that people
drink and use drugs and hurt themselves
like that is shame and when you shame
them it just makes it worse so if you
are in a relationship with someone who's
addicted to something it is your job to
study addiction and learn how it works
and to not make it worse for them i'm
not saying it's okay to do all the
fucked up shit walk away or walk away
right because you're you're
what i've learned of when you have an
addict in your life and you're telling
them
you need to get sober and you need to do
this if they do it for you it's never
going to take right but also if you're
like you need to fucking stop drinking
and you're a piece of shit because you
use and you need to use more yeah well
you're just as the
therapist said to me which i have to
defer to people that have degrees in
this you're just going to kill them
faster you're killing them yeah because
you're giving them more shame right you
need to get away from them right get
away from them right you're killing them
and if you need to
criticize someone and be the hero and be
the um person who is superior that's
your sickness and you need to go to a
program where you need to not feel
superior because your self-worth is so
fucking low that you need to be superior
to someone who's sick yeah
like how sad is that so when i hear that
i just go oh my god this person that
needs to be anesthetized because he's so
traumatized and whatever this person is
screaming get fucking sober why aren't
you taken to a meeting why haven't you
googled how ama works yeah but yeah
yeah it's also just like she's also i'm
not and like this bit is over for me
like i'm done being an amber heart
but she's i think she's also
damaged
you know what i mean like which is human
magnet syndrome right
this is not normal you can
he also should do the same work that
we're asking her to do right you know
absolutely and just watch
what and this is i think that the the
point of all this right is to go
as someone that lost a lot of time right
to
minimizing rationalizing
um needing to be superior trying to fix
other people that have
millions of dollars i mean he's got he's
he can fix himself if you leave he will
be fine you did not need to yell at him
right you're a kid but i know what that
um human magnet syndrome is i know what
that hooking in is
and i guess
the same way maybe someone says like hey
if you like are 25 and you take a couple
hits a blow and you love it and it makes
you feel quote normal
don't ever do it again right right i
don't expect you to to um
take my advice or
but this is going to get in your head
and it's going to change you yeah and
you might do it again and again and
again but you might go ugh that fucking
cunt whitney
said that and there's something there so
that's how i change people said shit to
me that i was like oh fuck this person
like oh i went to all these meetings and
i was like yeah god i'm different than
you uh you're just jealous you fucking
old hag you don't know what you're
talking about but it gets in your
fucking hippocampus but how
heartbreaking that's right but how
heartbreaking if they don't ever have
someone in their life to do that do you
know what i mean correct absolutely
which means
you know all all i'm saying is that i
think that i think people sometimes look
to me in this podcast and us from
business advice right career advice life
advice relationship advice
you for beauty advice because you're
breathtaking um uh which is that
if you're in a relationship like this
uh
get help it's addictive and it never
changes
[Music]
bye
[Music]
[Applause]